that's rag on my Star Wars sure for the
solo Star Wars movie trailer which is
coming tomorrow so now we're I guess
we're gonna talk about Jurassic world
following Kingdom because as the
argument is Super Bowl time is very
expensive that's why they're showing the
full trailer to so low tomorrow
well Jurassic world fallen Kingdom gave
us a legit trailer so Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom of the first trailer came
out and I was like it's about an
exploding island yeah right and the
Internet of course was like actually
it's beginning of movies now home sure
enough you see like a shot of it but
that's it because after that you see
that the dinosaurs apparently come to
the mainland because we think about the
sweetest part in the lost world we think
about that time the t-rex came to the
mainland we done what his dinosaurs are
bad news and they're killing people
again which spoiler they get blue they
save Dino lastly at the beginning now we
know that but this trailer really does
reinforce the Jurassic Park or world is
a monster movie now this is what it is
when you have shots like this it's a
monster movie even though it's the
toe-tapping thing which is really funny
to man cuz when I saw the original
Jurassic Park I thought the toe tap is
like ooh mmm where are they but really
what he's doing is he's giving signals
to the other velociraptor this one who's
the dinosaur giving signals to there's
no one else there no other dinosaurs in
this there is i'm not pumped that
there's this kids sidekick in the movie
that makes sounds like this I just think
that's gonna detract from the whole
thing
character-wise don't like it personally
I'm glad that that can you know that's
the best moment that kid's life I mom I
landed a role in the new Jurassic Park
movie good for you kid I think that's
awesome that said that characters
probably gonna annoy me I call him kid
I'm assuming he's a she's probably my
age or Chris Pratt calls him kid my dad
yeah kid so I'm calling kid I imagine by
the time I upload this video there will
be 27 other movie trailers or teasers
for teaser trailers that are coming
tomorrow that air than the Super Bowl
but they're actually teasers for teasers
and now we're teased this is the
marketing budget rising world fallen
Kingdom monster movie could be fun not
holding my breath the magic of what
Jurassic Park was is not really
translating into this new wave of movies
kinda like Star Wars whatever I said it
I meant it as I wear Star Wars
old-school shirt that's what gets my
dick but the Superbowl trailer for
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]